there are no traditional solutions to
monitor those breathing hazards
everywhere
for example in the u.s more than 120
million americans
lives in areas that have no sensors no
epa sensors at all at their location
so basically you know in some areas the
government municipalities are blind they
don't know exactly
what the people are within welcome to
20-minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctec
what could be more important than the
air we breathe around us
meet ron korber ceo and co-founder of
brezometer
run is the ceo and co-founder of
brizometer his burning ambition is to
improve the health and quality of life
for billions of people across the globe
by providing accurate
and actionable air quality data as
co-founder and ceo at breezeometer he is
proud to be able to work towards
bringing dreams to fruition every day
john kobel welcome to 20 minute leaders
all the way from joachim elite
brizometer how are you i'm doing great
thank you so much for inviting me
michael
thank you for being here one of the
things that i'm most excited about is
companies that are leveraging technology
to find the intersection between
different industries and one of the
things that i that i immediately took
attention to when i when i visited your
website and i looked at your product is
this idea that
you know we there's so much information
out there about our environment about
the air around us that
we don't even realize and we don't even
realize how it may be relevant for the
products we build in the day-to-day
and and i think that it's it's extremely
interesting and i and i'd love to hear a
little bit about the founding story of
brizometer how you started it i believe
seven or eight years ago
and then a little bit about high level
how does this impact our world and how
is this relevant
for you know our society today great
great so i'll be happy to
you know share our story so as a way of
introduction
i am an environmental engineer i
graduated from the technion like the
israeli mit
and i have almost 15 years of practical
engineering and management experience
and we founded brusometer in order to
help improve the health of billions of
people worldwide who might be exposed to
environmental hazards
in order to do so we establish a team of
experts in the field of atmospheric
science environmental engineers like
myself
big data experts and machine learning
and ai experts and by combining those
skills and technologies we are able to
provide the most accurate forecast and
health insights
on environmental hazards such as air
pollution
wildfires and pollen and the idea for
mapping environmental hazards started in
2012 and my wife and i were looking to
buy a house
in israel at that time and my wife is
asthmatic and in that specific time she
was pregnant with her first child
as an environmental engineer i knew that
short-term
exposure to air pollution for even less
than one hour
can increase the risk for many
respiratory diseases and also air
pollution is the leading environmental
cause for premature
death and a dominant cause for premature
wealth so we
were looking for air quality information
that could tell us
what is the air pollution levels at the
specific address we wanted to buy a
house
we did find some information but the
data as you mentioned
was scattered was incomprehensible
and not per address at all so therefore
together with brussometer co-founder
emil fisher
who is a talented brilliant software
engineer and also my
best friend we developed an algorithm
that can help us
choose the healthiest place to live we
soon realized that
it's not only a challenge for us in
israel it's a global challenge
and in many countries you know many
people don't have a clue
about what they breed and what
environmental hazards
they might face and you know moving
forward to
2021 every day more than 300 million
people
use our platform to make informed
decision on how to avoid
those environmental hazards and our
solution is being used by leading brands
such as astrazeneca dyson bosch l'oreal
verizon and the list goes on
so on one hand you have the engineering
part which is
realizing okay this is how you measure
the air pollution expectancy of wildfire
etc etc
what i'm curious though about is then
the implementation in the real world so
you're mentioning
some amazing companies that are making
use of this you're mentioning that 300
million people are making use of this on
a daily basis to be more informed and
make better decisions
how does this actually you know coming
to the practical world
i'm sitting here beautiful you know
window beautiful day
how do i as a consumer inter interact
with this idea of you know air pollution
and and and the environment through the
technology
yeah so i think a great example is the
famous apple weather app
you know one of the new features in
apple weather app on iphone include the
introduction
of breezometer industry-leading air
quality data
as part of the new ios 14.3 update and
the other updates users of the apple
weather app on iphone
can view hyper local air quality data
from bursometer
of course we couldn't be more you know
excited
and proud of that uh you know air
pollution levels can change
drastically throughout the course of the
day and even
in very short instances every few meters
and
you know all fit so our hyper local air
quality data is available whenever you
are
looking the apple weather app in
currently
in the us uk germany india and mexico
so this is one real world example and if
you are i remember
i remember when i visited it when i
visited china with my family
and we arrived and one of the things
that we had to start getting into the
habit of doing was checking the air
pollution
in in the in the area we're in because
at on some levels it got
so bad that we couldn't be in the area
or we had to wear masks or something
this is obviously before kobet
here when we're living in in you know
different places in the world where we
don't feel necessarily the implications
of air pollution on us how relevant is
this
to to me to my understanding of the
world or how i interact with the world
right now
yeah so i will be happy to to share some
statistics if we look on
only the us we'll start with the u.s for
example so in the u.s alone there are
almost
40 million copd or asthma patients who
are
most sensitive to air pollution and
about
70 million people that suffers from
seasonal allergies
due to pollen and that create a huge
healthcare cost
for example 30 of the doctor visits
during pollen season is due to seasonal
allergies
and if we look worldwide according to
the world of organization
air pollution is the single biggest
environmental health risk
that is linked to the death of more than
eight
million people every year and the
healthcare cost
of air pollution wow which is only one
environmental hazards out of a range of
environmental hazards which we forecast
is more than 5 trillion
and only in dollars and only globally so
it's a huge healthcare cost
so if it's such a huge huge thing how
come i don't hear about this in the day
today
how do why you know i'm looking at the
the startup ecosystem
and you know so many incredible people
that are working on different
things why don't i hear about air
pollution and these sorts of
technologies
you know as a mainstream type of thing
because it sounds to me like this is
something that we should all be
not just excited about solving but
should be actually concerned with
as we go about our own lives exactly so
so another challenge which is even a
bigger challenge
is that there is also an information gap
and there are no traditional solutions
to monitor
those breathing hazards everywhere for
example in the u.s
more than 120 million americans lives in
areas
that have no sensors no epa
sensors at all at their location so
basically you know in some areas the
government municipalities are blind they
don't know exactly
what the people are within another
very interesting fact about air
pollution and poland and other
environmental hazards
is that most of the time they are
extremely dynamic
much more than weather and fast changing
for example air pollution
can fluctuate on an hourly basis and can
show different results at any given time
form street street and this is because
of us human activity now impact on air
pollution
for example traffic jams log down which
we
experienced last year power plants
emissions all of those
parameters impact air pollution levels
so you know before without
the traditional air pollution
forecasting services whether it's the
governments or
other companies basically use very basic
data
that didn't provide the full picture and
therefore
you couldn't spock speak about it you
couldn't share information about that
because the information
wasn't there and of course we solved
this challenge by developing very
sophisticated ai and machine learning
algorithms
that crunch thousands of different data
sources
for millions of observations making the
invisible visible
like we like to say
so one of the things that you mentioned
before was that there is a limitation
for 120 million people in the us
because there is no sensors or physical
instruments in the area to help monitor
are those things being mitigated now by
technology by software that doesn't
necessarily need
those precision instruments yeah so this
is exactly
you know what we have done you know for
example
in those locations in order to
accurately forecast air pollution
we leverage exclusive access to
real-time traffic data derived from
vehicle sensors from smartphones
and tens of millions of connected cars
our unique set of ai and machine
learning algorithms enable us to use
this exclusive data
in order to provide very accurate air
pollution forecasts
which calculate the impact of current
traffic on pollution
another example is in the case of
wildfires
you know in areas that have no sensors
we leverage exclusive access to
state-of-the-art
fire smoke data derived from
universities and
research institute basically every time
somebody sees smoke in california and
you call 9-1-1
we can pinpoint the location of this
wildfire
and using very sophisticated algorithms
which we develop
we can focus how the smoke from the
fires
will impact air pollution levels nearby
so whenever you are missing some
information by using sophisticated
machine learning and ai algorithms you
can bridge this gap
and forecast the air pollution levels at
those specific locations
right and so if we look at this you know
two three years down the line or even a
little bit more and we look at
you know the mapping of the world and
how we're all interacting obviously we
know that
that you know the pollution is not it's
not getting better for a variety of
reasons
and so the problem is is going to be
with us for for quite some time
what what is the you know where are we
headed with this
what is sort of the mission or the
vision that you see
either with griezometer or with the
industry in general
yeah that's that's a great question so
first of all
you know by now we all experience how
climate change
impact many different parameters we see
that
pollen season for example is getting
longer
in big parts of the world we also see
those extreme weather events you know
typhoon toronados are becoming more
frequent
and more hazardous we also see the
impact
of climate change on on air pollution
especially
you know for example a dust storms
that are becoming more frequent and you
know what we believe
that at breezometer is that using our
core
technology and our you know the
experience we have gained
uh in in the last several years we will
be able to decr democratize
other environmental data become the
google
of environmental data you know so far we
have
succeeded to provide the most accurate
insights on air quality pollen
and wildfires and what we are passionate
about
is to use our core technology and our
team expertise
to expand our forecasting capabilities
to forecast
other environmental hazards that are
becoming also more frequent for example
earthquakes
for example alerts about water
contamination about radiation
and other environmental hazards that
might impact billions of people
worldwide
so this is what we are striving to do
and and this is what we are here for
you know i think that one thing that i
have to mention you know we're sitting
here and we're talking about forecasting
earthquakes and
and wildfires and and you know it sounds
a little bit
you know um theoretical when we talk
about it in this way but at the end
you know it's real people and it's real
lives of people it's the quality of
people
all the way from people who have asthma
and their quality of life all the way to
people who are
going to be in danger in this in the
scenario and i
you know coming from my own home and my
dad
leads the crisis response for for google
and they do
a lot of flood predictions and i you
know i get to i got to talk to him and
to hear he went he traveled to india
and you know all of a sudden it goes
from okay there's
millions of people affected but then you
meet the actual people that are living
there
and and you know the perspective changes
and i can just see the passion that
he brings to it and so i can completely
see you know why you've been working on
this for so long and the impact that
this can have
tell me a little a little bit back to
the air pollution today and you
mentioned that there are a variety of
companies already integrating with
breathometer
how does it actually how do they
actually make use of it how does for
example dyson use it or
i understand you know the weather apps
but what are some interesting use cases
that perhaps even may have surprised you
as you've been integrating with a lot of
these companies
yeah that's a great question you know
just to add to
to your last you know last comment about
your father
you know think about the the people that
works at wizometer we are
very privileged and very proud of what
we do and
we are still relatively a very small
company we
are a team of 50 people you know 50
people
who have different expertise
environmental engineers and software
engineers and machine learning experts
but eventually only 50 people
that have the privilege to serve more
than 300 million people on a daily basis
and actually help them to improve their
health help them to improve their
well-being
and help them to even you know you know
reduce
the risk of life-threatening events for
example fires
so so this is you know thanks to the
development of technology and we're very
proud of that
uh to answer your questions you know a
great example which we're very proud of
is in the field of healthcare for
example among our customers in the field
of healthcare
is propeller by resmed which is a very
famous california based
medical equipment company with over of 2
billion
of annual revenues and resmed primarily
provide cloud connectable medical
devices for the treatment of asthma copd
and other respiratory conditions and
breezometer
insight engine which is powering
propeller app provide a highly
personalized predictive service
that notify asthma or copd patients
whenever their personal asthma forecast
might be poor for example
if the pollen count is high at an
individual location
the propeller health app will warn this
individual
so he can take action ahead of the time
for example closing the windows
or turning his air purifier or even
use preventative medication to make sure
that he doesn't experiencing
any symptoms and resmed app
powered by our technology have delivered
astonishing outcome
to over 100 000 asthma and copd patients
in clinical
trials what they have found out that
using our service
we can help reduce emergency department
visits by more than
57 percent think how much it's crucial
during the pandemic
we can help reduce asthma attack by
almost
80 percent to those 100 thousand
patients
wow those one hundred and thousand
asthma and super
copd asthma patient had fifty percent
more symptoms three days so they
actually lived
you know better more healthy lives and
we couldn't be more proud of those
results
i think that you're working on a some of
the most exciting and impactful things
that
are possible and i can only imagine you
know now you're talking about
300 million but but really you know the
audience is
you know eight billion or seven billion
i can't even keep up with
with our population and so i can only
imagine you know where it's going to go
from here
uh 20 minutes go by very very fast but i
do have time for a few short questions
are you ready yes i'm ready
all right favorite subject in school k
to 12
uh biology full show
biology why biology i i
truly like that you know the world is a
very complex
complex organism and you know
once you deep dive on that you actually
understand that everything is connected
and this is why i also went to learn
environmental engineering
as an environmental engineer you use
different
organism to help save or
you know increase wellness for other
organisms as well
so you use the entire environment as a
lab
for you and and it's very you know i i
was very passionate about that at school
and still very
you know passionate about that so
biology for sure
very cool okay one of your role models
and professionally personally a role
model
yeah so elon musk and if you want
another one peter thiel
they used to work together they competed
even with each other at some point
of time so yeah so those are my two
favorites for sure
why why why those two specific i think
you know
elon musk you know by now prove that
everything that you
think can can happen if you focus
on developing the best product the best
technology
you know and so so i you know i truly
admire him i think many many many people
by now admire him so it's you know it's
it's it's not uh uh something that might
surprise
uh peter thiel on the other hand you
know while elon musk is very focused on
the product and tech you know peter
thiel was more focused on
building a culture building a teamwork
building a business thinking about
you know how the business can create a
monolith
monopoly or how you can compete so i
both of them very very successful both
of them eventually work together
at some point competing with each other
and
it's a special times when you have those
amazing entrepreneurs
you know doing great things in the world
wonderful three words you would use to
describe yourself
uh so first optimistic i am very very
optimistic
uh the the next
you know i think will be cool it takes a
lot
of work to try to make me less cool or
unhappy you know when the pandemic hit
and and nasdaq collapsed and and most
uh you know most many entrepreneurs
received emails from their boss about
laying off people
i was actually excited about you know
facing this opportunity facing this
challenge
and i was you know super cool about not
doing
uh a fast you know mistake
uh world number three
uh i think a father yeah a father you
know uh
even now you know although i'm super
passionate about what i'm
i'm doing you know being a father is is
something that i'm most proud of
yeah amazing
thank you very very much this was a
wonderful keep making the positive
impact thank you for spending
these 20 minutes with me i really
appreciate it and stay safe and stay
healthy yeah you too thank you so much
[Music]
you